this video is part of the biggest
collaboration ever done on youtube where
creators from around the world are
making videos about our planet's ocean
to support the team seas campaign in
order to raise 30 million dollars to
clean 30 million pounds of trash from
the ocean
and curiosity stream has donated their
sponsor time so i can tell you all about
it but first let's talk about why it's
so important
turtles have been walking the earth and
swimming in the seas for a remarkably
long time
around 210 million years ago the first
primitive turtle with a shell emerged
during the triassic period it was
largely terrestrial and had a beak and
armored shell just like modern turtles
this was the era of the first dinosaurs
and an era that gave rise to a huge
explosion of diversity on the planet but
it was an era that did not last forever
200 million years ago massive volcanic
activity changed the earth's climate and
the end triassic mass extinction event
occurred killing 76
of all marine and terrestrial species
however the lineage of the turtles held
on 80 million years later during the
cretaceous period the first turtles to
live exclusively in a marine environment
emerged eventually four families of sea
turtles came to exist and some members
of these families were incredible
the giant archelon was the largest sea
turtle to ever live
it was three meters long and weighed
almost 2
000 kilograms
but these giants too did not last
forever
66 million years ago the asteroid event
that wiped out the dinosaurs also wiped
out two of the four sea turtle families
75
of all species on earth went extinct
during this time
but two families of sea turtles
withstood this apocalypse and continue
to swim in the seas to this day
one sea turtle family of soft shell sea
turtles has just one remaining member
the leatherback sea turtle the other six
sea turtle species belong to another
family of hard-shelled turtles
today's turtles are a reminder of the
resilience of their lineage and of their
adaptability in the face of epic
extinction events events the likes of
which are hard to even imagine
but their resilience is not infinite and
today they are being put to the ultimate
test
numerous experts believe we are living
through or on the cusp of a new mass
extinction event the sixth in the
history of our planet
one not caused by asteroids or volcanoes
but by human activity this extinction
event called the holocene extinction
event began around 10 000 years ago when
the last ice age came to an end and
humans began spreading and hunting
across the earth
since then there has been a steady
decrease in the number of species that
live on our planet however in recent
years the extinction rate has
skyrocketed the number of species on our
planet plummeting
deforestation driven by agriculture and
meat consumption overfishing ocean
acidification habitat loss the world
over and pollution driven by increased
human consumption are all forces that
may prove to be worse for biodiversity
than a literal apocalyptic asteroid
and the resilient sea turtles who have
endured so much are one of the types of
animals most at risk
their particular physiology making them
vulnerable to our particular ways of
messing with the environment
the adaptations that allowed them to
survive for so long are the very reasons
they are in grave danger in today's
world
but unlike global volcanic eruptions
this is an extinction event we can
actually do something about
yes humans are the ones doing the damage
but we are also the ones who can come up
with the solutions
sea turtles spend nearly all of their
time in the open ocean
submerged in solitary for the majority
of their lives
however there is one exception to this
entirely oceanic life
when female sea turtles come ashore to
lay clutches of eggs
after a long migration they make their
way back to their home beach the same
beach where they hatched and the only
beach they will ever return to they
heave their bodies onto land and dig an
egg chamber about 80 centimeters deep
here the turtle will lay around a
hundred ping-pong sized eggs then fill
the hole and head back to the sea
over the next two months the eggs
develop and undergo temperature
dependent sex determination
this means that the temperature of each
egg during certain periods of
development determines the gender of the
baby sea turtle that hatches
warmer eggs produce females while cooler
eggs produce males
then it's time for the babies to go
forth into the world they chip their way
out of their eggs with their temporary
egg tooth and ready themselves for the
most perilous journey of their lives on
their mad dash to the ocean the turtles
face many dangers
predators like crabs dogs seagulls or
raccoons would love to make a nice snack
out of a baby turtle or two
the blazing hot sand can scorch their
bodies and for a tiny turtle the uneven
terrain must feel like navigating huge
sand dunes
but
evolution has helped the baby turtles
build impressive survival mechanisms to
navigate these dangers
they usually wait until nightfall to
make their mad dash to minimize the risk
of being seen as well as to avoid the
blazing hot sun
to make sure the turtles know where they
need to go at night time they have
evolved to be photo tactic meaning they
are attracted to light hatchlings will
move towards the brightest light source
which is usually the moonlight
reflecting off the sea for millions of
years this was an effective strategy a
powerful sense that pulled millions of
baby turtles towards their rightful home
but the clever evolution that has
allowed turtles to survive this
treacherous journey for so long is now
unfortunately leading them to their
demise
if artificial light sources like street
lights or lights from buildings are
present near the beach this can confuse
the hatchlings
they may mistakenly crawl towards the
brightly lit road and into highly
developed areas
here they can get hit by cars or
snatched up by predators attacked by
fire ants or simply get lost and die
on some beaches disorientation can
affect up to half of all hatchlings and
even if they realize their mistake and
turn around they might be too exhausted
by then to make it to the sea evolution
has not had a chance to catch up with a
human invention that has been in these
areas for sometimes only a few decades
but with some coordination this problem
could somewhat easily be reversed all
that's needed is to reduce the amount of
artificial light that is visible from
nesting beaches
lights can be given special fixtures to
direct the light away from the beach or
lamps can be implemented with light
bulbs that only emit red light which
isn't as visible to most animals windows
that face the beach can be tinted and
curtains can be drawn after dark to keep
the light out of sight
many coastal communities around the
world have past ordinances that require
residents to turn off beachfront lights
during turtle nesting season but
unfortunately these ordinances are not
always enforced
however even with partial compliance
thousands of baby sea turtles could be
saved every year
and in 2014
the sea turtle conservancy was awarded a
1.5 million dollar grant to expand
lighting retrofit work in the florida
panhandle more grants like this and more
cooperation from the public could help
sea turtles of all kinds withstand some
of the threat of extinction we are
forcing on them
this is a relatively simple example of
how working to understand sea turtle's
biology leads to effective conservation
but not all problems facing turtles come
from a single strip of land next to
their nesting habitat warming seas
pollution ocean plastic these are
problems the entire world is
contributing to
what solutions are there for problems so
complex
what hope do sea turtles have in this
onslaught of human impact
when the leatherback turtle evolved
around a hundred million years ago it
lived along other members of the dermo
kalliodi family and the other three
families of sea turtles that existed at
the time when the end cretaceous
extinction event occurred the going got
tough and competition between ocean
creatures for food became more intense
but leatherback turtles had a
specialized diet that helped them to
survive
a diet that few other sea creatures find
very appealing it's a menu with almost
no carbohydrates no fats no proteins
just a gelatinous salty package of
certain fatty acids and a handful of
calories each jellyfish
leatherback turtles surprisingly eat
almost nothing else
it's an odd choice but one that gave
them an edge helping them to survive a
cataclysmic extinction event
but just like with the turtles drawn to
streetlights the leatherback's love of
jellies now gets them into trouble when
they mix up their favorite snack with a
different clear amorphous floating item
plastic bags
the ocean plastic problem affects nearly
all of the animals that live in the sea
but turtles are one of the types of
animals most susceptible to its damage
an ingested plastic bag can cause
internal blockages which can lead to
starvation or death
sharp plastics can rupture internal
organs plastic straws can get caught in
their nostrils or they can get entangled
in discarded fishing nets which can
result in serious cuts on their bodies
or even drowning
and plastics that build up on nesting
beaches can prevent baby turtles from
reaching the sea
there is no area of the ocean that is
not affected by the 12 million metric
tons of plastic that end up in the ocean
every year a plastic bag was even found
at the bottom of the mariana trench 11
000 meters deep
so the chances of a turtle encountering
some plastic is very very high
but certain organizations are poised to
help if they get a call about a turtle
in distress
often a turtle needs surgery and months
of rehabilitation
this past year the new england aquarium
admitted
569 sea turtles for rehabilitation some
harmed because of plastic others from
boat strikes or cold shock
other times sea turtles just need
someone paying attention to help them
out just last month the new england
aquarium responded to a leatherback
turtle entangled in fishing gear off of
cape cod
the female turtle was successfully
evaluated disentangled and outfitted
with two electronic tags that will allow
researchers to assess survivorship over
the next 30 days and track her migration
patterns
the use of tags like this in sea turtles
will prove vital for long-term
monitoring they can provide up to a
decade of information about animal
movements and survival
saving individual turtles is a necessary
difficult job that is making a
difference in population numbers
however to truly help the turtles we
need to get to the source of the problem
the amount of trash we dump into the
ocean is expected to triple by 2040
unless we as a species across every
country do something about it there are
a few key things we need to do to stop
this trend
the first is to simply stop producing so
much [ __ ] plastic perhaps with taxes
and incentives to get companies to knock
it off
another is to design packaging so that
it must be recyclable or compostable
and another is to expand waste
collection infrastructure in middle and
low-income countries
plastic obviously has its place and
sometimes is essential but most of what
we use it for is totally not
meaningful change will have to come from
commitments from governments around the
world
but with any hope one day we'll get
there until then efforts are focused
around cleanup efforts like catching
trash that flows from rivers before it
ends up in the ocean after all eighty
percent of river plastic comes from just
a thousand rivers in the world
if we can catch the plastic at its
source
so much damage to the ocean could be
prevented
and this is exactly what the ocean
cleanup project is working to do
they've invented a solar-powered trash
interceptor where trash flowing down the
river is guided to a conveyor belt and
then loaded into a dumpster which is
then taken to a waste facility
currently there are only three
interceptors deployed one in indonesia
one in malaysia and one in the dominican
republic
to scale the project up to tackle a
thousand rivers more government
cooperation is needed and also more
funding
and this is the purpose of team seas
team seas is a global campaign to raise
30 million dollars to remove 30 million
pounds of plastic and trash from our
oceans rivers and beaches where one
dollar equals one pound of trash removed
donations will be split between the
ocean cleanup project and the ocean
conservancy
this is a refreshing chance to actually
do something about the problems we hear
so much about
and that's why our team at real science
and real engineering decided to donate
five thousand dollars to clean up five
thousand pounds of trash
and if you want to donate some yourself
you should head to teamsees.org
as for hope for the turtles
in the 1940s incredible video was taken
of what is now estimated to be around 40
000 kemp's ridley turtles nesting in one
area
a turtle that today is the rarest and
most endangered of all sea turtles
by 1985 only 700 nests for this turtle
were found worldwide the entire year
the kemp's ridley turtle was on a fast
track to extinction due to human damage
but thanks to conservation efforts the
trend slowly turned in the early 2000s
a combination of nesting beach
protection and improved fisheries
regulation
saved this rarest of all sea turtles
from the brink of extinction and is now
estimated to be over 22 000 individuals
strong
with more hard work these numbers can
continue to improve
hope for the turtles is very much alive
we can do better we already have and we
already are
you